spider-man his great comic book covers
for nearly 70 years and the friendly
neighborhood hero has shown up in
countless video games since the early
80s
he's appeared in the Marvel vs. Capcom
in Lego series but he's also starred in
his own games on so many platforms from
the Atari 2600 to the ps4 but with
dozens of web slinging adventures out
there which ones are really worth your
time we looked at the last 30 plus years
of video game history to pick out the
eight best spider-man games you know
eight because like spiders have eight
legs and well anyway we limited the list
two games strictly starring Spidey and
we're gonna present them chronologically
there's no ranking here first up we're
going all the way back to 1991
spider-man the video game is a coin-op
arcade machine that mixed beat'em up and
platforming it was far from Spidey's
first game but this one gets bonus
points for offering two different styles
of gameplay and the game transitions
between radically zoomed in and out
cameras to show the action while
fighting or highlight the rest of the
city while exploring now we'll jump
ahead to 2000 when the simply titled
spider-man launched on ps1 and n64 those
platforms assured in the era of 3d
console games and Spidey was there to
crawl on walls swing from buildings and
beat up bad guys in a whole new
dimension it was a treat to see classic
villains like scorpion and Doc Ock in a
totally new way and each stage is
presented in a classic comic-book style
with appropriate fonts for dialogue and
loading screens that display comic book
cover art Sam Raimi spider-man trilogy
was a smash hit in the early aunts and
both Tobey Maguire and Willem Dafoe
added their voices to the first licensed
video game this adaptation from Treyarch
stands out for not just letting me play
through the events of the movie but for
incorporating a bunch of new scenes and
villains who didn't show up on the big
screen the icing on the cake here is a
bonus mode that lets you play any level
as the green goblin in an alternate
timeline where a different more evil
goblin has been hired by Oscorp and if
we're gonna talk about games based on
movies we have to talk about spider-man
2 for the first time you could freely
move around the city exploring all of
Manhattan Plus Ellis Roosevelt and
Liberty Islands
for a long long time spider-man 2 was
the model for Spidey's movement using
physics to determine the path of his web
swings the open world was full of side
quests to complete to letting you rank
up your hero level to continue the main
story trailer took a step away from the
movies to put its own spin on ultimate
spider-man the first time a Spidey game
broke from the regular Marvel Comics
line like spider-man 2 this game let you
freely explore Manhattan and Peter
Parker's home borough of Queens but the
biggest difference is that you don't
just play as Spidey the plot is split
between spider-man and venom who has a
much more brutal combat style and not
just because he has to eat people to
stay alive both characters have their
own plots and side quests that weave
together in a story involving Peter
Parker and Eddie Brock's parents if
playing is both good and evil characters
an ultimate spider-man sounds cool then
you'll love what web of Shadows brings
to the table this game focused on the
internal clash between Spidey and the
symbiote letting you switch between the
red and black suits at any time each
with their own powers but it's not just
about what spider-man looks like
throughout the game you can choose
between good or evil actions and even
which villains you want to fight web of
Shadows has multiple endings based on
your decisions changing which female
companion Spidey ends up with and even
determining whether or not he ends the
game as an actual good guy that cause
and effect goes even further in
spider-man edge of time this game also
features two heroes jumping between the
regular webhead and spider-man 2099 each
with their own abilities and skill trees
each hero is actually trapped in the
other's timeline in actions taken by
spider-man 2099 in the past actually
alter the future for the other
spider-man there's definitely a lesson
here about messing with time travel and
finally we have to talk about the most
recent Spidey game Marvel's spider-man
comes from insomniac the team that
brought us Ratchet and Clank and sunset
overdrive games that emphasize creative
use of gadgets and freedom of movement
insomniacs take on spider-man just feels
good whether you're slinging webs or
swinging punches at bad guys the
original story is packed with great
moments but if you just want to explore
the city there are plenty of side quests
and optional objectives to extend your
stay in New York
and it's definitely the standard for
Spidey games from here on out so those
are our picks for the best spider-man
games if you've got a favorite that
didn't make the list let us know in the
comments and for an even deeper look
back at Spidey's past you can always
check out our video on the history of
spider-man games
[Music]